the Star Wars franchise is about to
venture into territory previously
uncharted but is the high-stakes mission
a hits or a mess general audiences won't
be able to tune in to the first ever
live-action Star Wars series the
Mandalorian until it hits the upcoming
streaming sites at Disney Plus on
November 12th further number of lucky
critics have already gotten the chance
to catch about a half hours worth of
footage from the show during a special
Disney event held on October 19th taking
to social media these critics have
spilled their spoiler-free thoughts on
the Mandalorian and things are looking
brighter than c-3po after a buff and
shine in fact many have praised the
forthcoming series everything they had
hoped for and then some gear surrounds
up of the first reactions to the
Mandalorian one of the biggest takeaways
from the early reaction so that
Mandalorian is that it's kick-ass
action-packed and basically everything a
Star Wars fan could want from a
live-action series from what critics
have seen so far it sounds like the set
pieces aesthetic characters and story of
the show all come together to make for a
series of fans of the franchise would
love Collider editor-in-chief Steven
Weintraub said in his reaction this is
the Star Wars thing I've been waiting
for while I love the Skywalker saga I
wanted to see new characters and places
explored in death which can only be done
over multiple episodes in a series
format cannot wait to see more he
continued it's as awesome as you wanted
to be can't say anything specific but
one scene answered a question that I
don't think has ever been explained
shown in any Star Wars movie love
thought it opens up the Star Wars
universe in a cool new way Star Wars
social media manager michelle bachman
tweeted her prediction that fans will be
pleased by the Jon Favreau created
series which she said reminded her of
old studio westerns of the 40s and 50s
with a dash of samurai movie vibes mixed
in a Star Wars II blender actress and
host Jennifer Lada felt similarly
writing all I have to say is this is a
epic Star Wars show we've been waiting
years for please pardon my excitement
she then clarified that she has nothing
but love for the animated Star Wars
series that have come before like the
Clone Wars rebels and resistance but if
you're holding out hope for a
live-action series Amanda
Orion is he answer to your prayers
Entertainment Tonight producer and
online host ash cross in was moved to
tears after watching footage from the
mandalorian signaling that a series has
powerful enough to make viewers
incredibly emotional given its quality
and it's true to Star Wars feel she
tweeted after the exclusive screening
events just watched 27 minutes of
Mandalorian footage and legit cried
can't say much but this is real and it's
happening and it feels so freakin Star
Wars drew Taylor former managing editor
a movie phone and current co-host of the
podcast like the fuse and fine tuning
was totally blown away by the
Mandalorian for a different reason
for Taylor the best part of the footage
he saw was its twist
apparently the character played by Nick
Nolte isn't Who fans might think he is
Taylor wrote in a to tweet to thread on
Twitter Wow the Mandalorian is
completely amazing saw nearly a half
hour of footage from what I was told
with the first three episodes whoever
you think Nick Nolte is the answer will
surprise you also it looks as expensive
as it is
they didn't skimp with this one
spaceships creatures etc all in full
effects cannot wait for full episodes
Eric Goldman of get fandom praised the
mandalorian as being both very cool and
very atmospheric with Pedro Pascal
Stitch Allah Carter having what it takes
to immediately captivate audiences
whatever like to be the mandalorian well
just look at the image he also compared
the series to a couple of action heavy
films that he's a fan of writing it's
sometimes evoke in the vibe of rogue one
which I adore the title character is
instantly fascinating and there are
great action and suspense moments
including some predator vibes
award-winning writer and Rotten Tomatoes
approved critic Rosie night gave perhaps
the coolest and most promising take on
the mandalorian when she tweeted
reliving my childhood Saturday mornings
watching Star Wars the 30 or so minutes
of the mandalorian footage we saw was
incredibly cool the samurai infused
space Western your boys wanted with a
nice cold lead a bunch of rad creatures
and
SCOR indieWIRE critic tyler her schoo
tweeted that the mandalorian exceeded
expectations and should serve as a major
hit for disney plus thanks to its high
production value he wrote I just got out
of the Mandalorian press screening and
gotta say really surpassed expectations
this seems like a truly high budget
movie like projects if other flagship
Disney Plus series have a similar
production quality a streaming service
will definitely have a strong run added
Screen Rant features a determined sewer
Mitty wallah saw almost 30 minutes of
the mandalorian footage this morning
it's truly incredible
it looks like the film's feels innately
Star Wars introduces new concepts and
that's layers that people have been
waiting to see for a long time audiences
at home can witness the Mandalorian and
Aulus of power and glory when it hits
the Disney Plus platform on November
12th check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
by your favorite TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the Bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]